hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round five of the
Kashima Memorial we said that we will
cover at least one more game and even
though the title says in navara vs.
Navarre don't worry it's not a typo
there's a very good reason for that
which will be explained during the video
but it's in fact David Navarro with the
white pieces facing Dingley right and
without further ado let's check it out
it's well it's a crazy game but what
else can you expect when when when the
thing is playing so Navarro opens with
d4 with Knight to f6 Knight to f3 d5 c4
and east 6 we have the Queens gambit
declined on the board Knight to c3
we have c6 transposing into the semi
Slav with III Knight B to d7 Bishop to
d3 and here D captures on c4 of course
as you roll black waits for wife to
develop the light square bishop and only
then captures on c4 forcing whites to
waste the tempo with Bishop captures on
c4 and then out b5 the neuron variation
Bishop goes back to the three and now
just a6 consolidating that a very nice
pawn structure on the Queen side we have
E for by white and here c5 a very very
sharp line where didn't continue not
sorry Navarro continues II five and the
dingoes C captures on d4 and here Knight
captures on b5 this is the bloomenfeld
variation extremely sharp line a capture
some before and now pawn captures on f6g
captures on f6 and now we have castles
and here comes the reason why the title
says its navara versus navara here after
Queen to b6 we have Queen to e2 by white
and the now comes b4 by black and it's
this is the position in the Vera had
last year in 2018
against Luba move - Nick and Navarre I
had the the black pieces here so here I
think Lorraine is using the same line
and Navarro used in 2018 to defeat his
opponent with the black pieces but here
it seems that navara analyzed this game
and here Nevarez opponent went looked at
e1 but here it's actually
Navarro who deviates from the line he
goes Bishop to f4 and now okay it's not
a new
it has been played before but it's
interesting because the ding which is
the one who chooses the defense after
after all d4 was played he chose most
likely to play in the spirit of that
game number one with the black pieces
but now navara forces him to to find a
different approach okay with h5 biding
and the now comes look after C 1 so the
rook is not being developed d1 this is
an improvement number I found over over
Luba metagenic
rather he chooses to develop the rook
over to c1 and already you can see that
there are a lot of interesting ideas if
you can play rook the system and bring
the other look to C 1 it can be just an
amazing C file for for the white rooks
so here
Bing closes it with Bishop to c5 not
allowing any rook or or bishop to c7
ideas for that matter and here there is
one game where Knight the d2 was played
going after the bishop on on c5 but here
we have a four again it's Navarro who
deviates and it is as of this moment
move 17 that we have a completely new
game so it's the Queen's game with a
client all other games and a lot of
variations are possible here so of
course will not have a new game from
move 10 but rather from move 17 but okay
dingos be captures on a3 I'm Poisson be
captures an a3 and now Bishop to e6 a
nice developing move offering a lot of
trades we have rook a to be one
attacking dings Queen and b6 and here we
go into a lot of crazy trades Bishop
captures on d3 with Queen captures on d3
and now here's a most likely the moment
where ding should have gone Queen to c6
but rather he goes where rook captures
on a3 we have Queen captures on a3
grabbing the rook Bishop captures on a3
grabbing the Queen now comes Luke
capture some b6 and here we have Bishop
captures on c1 so your Navarro here what
do you play here with the white pieces
I'll give you a couple of seconds you
know just to try and figure out what to
play here
for those of you who played Bishop
captures on c1 you would lose the rook
on d6 black would be ugly exchange here
and would have a winning game here
perhaps perhaps a move deemed missed
because he didn't play that Queen to c6
move but you know perhaps he saw it and
he decided that it's it's well worth it
but here we have looked the c6 by
Navarra getting the rook out of harm's
way
and now there's a double attack against
the bishop on c1 and of course if you
capture the bishop on f4 then rook the
c8 picks up the rook on h8 as the rockin
H it is undefended but as you cannot
prevent both Reds here it's actually
doing who has to give up the exchange
with Bishop captures rook the c8 check
King to e7 and now ding loses the rook
on h8 but this is why I said that maybe
he even saw everything and he just plays
d3 so all right he's down the exchange
but he has a very strong pass to D pawn
so let's see let's see how the game went
Navarro played King to f1 and as there's
no way of defending the h5 pawn ding
just brings the knight into the game
we have Knights to c5 and then out rook
captures on h5 threatening the night and
c5 Knight to e4 preparing to pull the
pawn all the way and here navara
calculates precisely he plays rook to h4
and it's very interesting here ding
actually wins wins the night we have
ePHI first defending the bishop here and
now comes g3 this is the move navara had
to find with d2 threatening of course
the one with a promotion to the Queen
Knight captures and d2 with Knight
captures and d2 with check if you ever
moved the bishop you're gonna lose this
knight Knight captures to wit check King
to e2 and now comes Bishop to g5 with an
attack against the rook and also the
night is still protected
looked before by navara and now again a
very interesting position where the
bishop is defending the knight but you
don't really you don't really have a
good way of saving it because yes for
the moment the bishop is defending it
but after f4 comes
well the bishop will no longer be
defending it and
why who white we'll just grab the night
and we'll be having a better endgame
being of the exchange so here being
played most likely he just he had to go
with the King King to d6 just start
marching his king forward but here he
played efore and E for just blunders
upon now it's very interesting how he
for blunder is a pawn
I will give you a couple of seconds as
it's really an an instructional or
educational if you would say endgame
where you know you're up the exchange
but you still have to play very precise
to win this so what do you play here
with white again I'll give you a couple
of seconds as it's a very nice position
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
in-game player and for those of you who
just wanna enjoy the show
rook to d4 and this is this is the idea
there's a double attack against the
night and e2 if you move the night you
lose d4 pawn if you don't do it let's
say you play something else for example
you could try kink the e6 or f5 doesn't
do it doesn't really matter
King e6 now white plays rook captures
and this is the point but it should
capture screen characters and the pawn
endgame is winning for white and it's
not and it's not all that's difficult of
an endgame let's say King e5 King III
you could go f5
then comes h4 now you don't really have
a lot of useful moves here you have to
go back King of six King at four king g6
and I are gonna go King e5 and after f6
let's taking a four and black has normal
moves as the pawns are doubled you would
have to move away from the points then
the white king will just gobble all of
them up so here ding realizes that he
doesn't have the luxury of going into a
King and pawn and game he decides to
give up the e4 pawn so we have Knight to
b3 rook captures with check King to d6
and now h4 pushing the Bushra back with
Bishop to h6 and now even h5 creating a
very nice pass pawn which is on a light
Square
King to d7 going back and then out look
the before attacking the knight and here
again nice the c5 seems like the safe
choice but it seems that dink dink is
still trying to win this position and
yes you do have a bishop
the night against the rope which is
usually enough for a win but you are
down upon but it's not just that you're
down upon you are down it's like you've
done two points because you're f-pawn is
doubled so here dingos nice to see one
check with King to f3 and now kink the
e6 and hear it there's a problem
we've looked the b6 check by navara kink
the f5 and now look the b5 check and now
you have to move and allow the white
king to approach we have King back to e6
now comes King to e4 and here you're
just gonna check the king you're gonna
approach these pawns you're gonna gobble
all of them up and then you're gonna
have a monster pawn storm on the King
side and the whites
well if extra night will will be a
little worth so here we have Knight to
e2 by dink but now comes Luke to b6
check pushing the King back kink the e7
and now not going after the pawns but an
even better move King 2 D 3 we have
Knight the c1 check kink the c4 now and
here ding still desperately tries to
bring the knight back into the game we
have nice the e1 but now it simply
doesn't work feel free to pause the
video and try to find it the winning
move for white here I'll give you a
couple of seconds for those of you that
were able to do it really
congratulations you are an excellent
trapper of knights and for those of you
who just want to enjoy show here navara
played rook to b1 and now it becomes
obvious the king and Knight occupy the
same the same line here rook to e1 is
the threat you definitely want to trap
that night and there's no other way you
can do it you can go Knight see one you
can go Knight c3 d4 is taken f4 is taken
you cannot go to g1 you can give up a
knife for a pawn but that doesn't really
do anything and the only thing you could
do is a very interesting line is King to
f8 and now after you go rook to e1 okay
you can go Knight c1 the bishop is still
controlling the c1 squared but here f4
you block the bishop defense and again
the only square available for the knight
is a 2 and after a 2 now rook to
one simply does simply trap the night
and here whatever you play doesn't
really matter kingly 7ro captures and
now it's an easily winning Indian for
white were still white is up upon about
black has a double death pawn and with
being of the exchange it's just an easy
win for white so here after rook to be
one Dingley rent resigned the game
that's something you hear very very
rarely it's like you will hear once a
year maybe that the ding loses the game
it's a you know like a solar eclipse
only much much rarer but yeah even even
the great king ding he's able of losing
the game now and then which is really
amazing he played he played the line
that navara used to beat at a bit
Lumiere - Nick and the Navarro improved
on it and then in a couple of positions
that Quinta c6 that the ding missed he
had to go into the line where he is done
the exchange I have not seen the
interview maybe he wanted to go into it
being down the exchange with to the past
deep on and he saw that he will win the
night but the Rope was just too strong
with the double left more and then again
he couldn't save the night and then he
decided to give up the e the e pawn to
save it and well that was just enough
for Navarro Navarro played a perfect
game which is you know that's at least
you have to play at least a perfect game
have to be to beat King ding and that's
what Navarro did so quite quite an
outstanding game by by Navarro and it's
interesting yeah I think also had a
couple of moments in the end game where
he could have gone back and maybe tried
to hold the draw but it seems that ding
was also trying to win this game which
he has to I mean he's he's over 2,800
you don't just stay there if you're
drawing in games where there's any fight
left but yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it
tough tough game for ding but I don't
think you'll take it too seriously I'm
sure he'll just you know improve and
maybe lose the next game in 2022 who
knows we'll see maybe in the candidates
this year it's hard to say but it did
prepare the standings after round 5 so
here it is Magnus Carlsen still in first
place with three and a half points
followed by Jonathan Anand after his
great victory we already seen it in the
preview
video followed by Sri Akal rock and also
with three points dinged now with two
and a half with in fourth place than
Navarro also with two and a half grease
shook also two and a half team or a job
of two and a half and then with two
points a clear Mahmoud Aravind Veselin
Topalov and in last place something you
don't see very often on each Gary who is
without a win so far and already two
losses definitely not his tournament and
he was so close to breaking 2800 I think
he was like three points away or maybe
even one point I'm not sure but he was
like really close to re-entering the
2800 Club so maybe he was just too
excited to join the club again and you
know it just it's just not his
tournament now but you know a lot of
games still to play we'll see how it
goes
sure and once again I would like to
thank Matt play against micro Cabral
initially but the pro lo William Miller
and Jana Schlesinger for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous video so your think all
for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content and yes for those of you
wondering we are definitely continuing
the cup of Blanca saga as soon as I you
know catch a break when I will have at
least a little bit more time in my day
to to do the saga simultaneously with
the current events in the world but
worry not it will continue so once again
thank you I'll see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day